so Olivia plays the Queen in this movie
yes and I was playing a queen in the
ground yep
what is it about her that she exudes
this royal kind of quality do you think
well I think Olivia can honestly I think
it's just coincidental but she's playing
two queens in a row
I think the Olivia can play truly
anything she is so genius I think she
can play anything I bet you guys how
much fun did you guys have together
she's she's one of the best people I've
ever met really I love her so much and I
love Rachel too it was just lívia it is
so interesting because she just like I
mean she yes she's playing a monarch in
this but this woman's like throwing
hissy fits all the time and having
meltdowns and it's just you know she's
just amazing there's a big obsession
with Harry and Megan yeah obviously
royalty do you have it as well this film
add to the increase of the royal family
hell yeah everything adds to the
intrigue of the royal family for me
really I'm into it I like I like
especially the opulence it's pretty
amazing it's pretty wild so you've been
a part of award season this is what your
third year because you did what 2016
with Lala yeah last year with battle the
sexes yeah and then this year with this
go well it's not I mean that I know but
you know you can actually live but can
you do do you feel like it's gonna end
up there or no I have no idea
you know embarrassing would it be if I
was like definitely and then it was like
no speaking and into fruition okay
whatever okay what about the idea of
competing with Rachel if both of you
guys are nominated in a supporting role
oh man I wouldn't see that as competing
I would just see that it's like this is
amazing yeah like you're your friend
yeah um I just think she's incredible
and she deserves everything were you
competitive growing up last your mom if
I said how would your mom say no no no
and it was actually part of the problem
with battle of the sexes my when I was
learning to play tennis because I wasn't
an athlete my brother's like a total
athlete so as my dad
to play tennis my tennis instructor was
eventually like you need to start
counting points start doing it and I'd
be like they'd be like okay where are we
who's winning and I was like have
literally no idea and they're like you
are not an athlete that's like you need
to think about winning in that way
okay what about jealousy would your mom
say your average jealousy yes I always
definitely jealous really but not
jealous of like people very rarely
jealous of like I'm I got into like a
little jealous phase but it's a deeper
therapy issue it's much better now I'm
not jealous we're sitting here right now
I'll tell you later
so could you relate so could you relate
your character in the movie then some of
those little definitely like the
darkness from when I was younger yeah I
could definitely understand some of the
things that drive her for sure and like
how that shadow side can get so insanely
powerful and overtakes so I mean I've
never done anything that Abigail has
done and certainly haven't wanted to
sabotage people but that like you really
see her get to the darkest place in the
end where she's like exercising her
power over a little helpless rabbit
there's no reason anymore for her to be
proving that she's in charge and it's
just that was an interesting scene to do
yeah it's fascinating but it's so much
fun to play because we all have these
parts of ourselves that we you know that
we can access and can get out of control
exactly so it's a cautionary tale in
some ways